sparky-sparky boom man see I can
remember that and I could say that I can
pronounce it more names like that so
don't you guys know that whenever we say
a name wrong it everyone goes nuts it
brings us such a joy it brings us such a
joy to see you get so angry we should
remember the names we should you know
that that's not fair to the people who
create the characters and you know
someone who just doesn't remember how to
pronounce it but you know I think like I
was heading out to come here actually
and and there's a power outage or
resulting in the Lord the Rings when
getting out lay so I had to rush then I
had to rush the sibling rivalry in these
Avatar videos I'm going through and
unpack and get all this stuff together
I'm going through my emails make sure
there's nothing else important about the
flight or anything it just says here's
how you pronounce gyro or whatever I'm
just like you know it's not number one
of my priorities right now so but know
we should remember we should know the
name so uh but regardless I probably
won't forget sparky-sparky boom man uh
with that said okay this is the runaway
uh and it's a top centered episode I
found tossed like really popular which
is I find very interesting not that
surprising you're on atomic characters
like that uh it's got some it's got some
good jokes in it the blind jokes
especially in this one really made me
laugh I think the only you kind of know
they're gonna do blind jokes the only
one that really ever made me laugh was
in when they were looking for the
library it was as she says something
like ice I found it like what where and
she's like oh that's what I'll say when
we eventually do find in a she just does
that and that's it's hilarious uh but
that's only time I left really hard
there's some really good ones in this
one the her playing dumb as the blind
person was Grady and I be even really
over like trying to find the bowls and
stuff I mean that was great uh everytime
they whipped out a piece of paper
a you know uh tough you know do you know
what this is and she's like well I'm
assuming a piece of paper but it's
what's on the piece of paper that's
important and then uh Katara does it
again then she's like what it's with you
people and it works so well because I
think I for a half a second forget too
that she can't read it or when they
write the letter on the the hawk
uh uh or the bird I like that there's a
bird now I think that's cool um and they
send it to Katara acting like it's
apology letter and she's like she can't
write so I verify stuff in this episode
uh we there's a very it's funny cuz
there's this really tender scene like
probably one of the most tender scenes
in there and that's when uh was it Sokka
Sokka and Toph are talking about why
Katara so motherly and why it's
important and bleah writing dialogue
like having Sokka forget his mother's
face I mean that's that's heavy stuff
that's like really heavy stuff that's a
hard thing for a kid to admit moment and
and even in the way it comes around to
that when he thinks of mother even the
term mother he thinks Katara now of
course she's in there and she's
listening to the whole thing but it's
and the way talks are opens up to about
you know suddenly her connection with
her parents or the lack thereof and the
choice she's made and and again knowing
that guitars down there hearing this -
and her reactions and the animation or
reactions uh all of that was just so
wonderful I just a really good
emotionally fueling moment and just
perfectly done uh it really was the
strongest in my opinion that this show
has had a lot of really good strong
emotional moments I thought that one was
very very nicely done but then okay not
a but it's not a but but both
it is still a great moment it's just
funny because a few moments later we
have we have Katara we have Toph in jail
and what even was the scene I can't
remember she's like you know I suddenly
thought of my parents and how much I
missed that if she gets teary I - Katara
hugs her for a second and it's so rushed
and it's it didn't need that I I don't
because you know she's gonna send a
letter at the end anyway and I think
it's or get it's gotten out with the
scene before we're Katara's listening I
I don't think you need that but again
that's um I'm only doing that because
it's avatar and not your everyday kids
family show so I again that's I'm only
saying it for that reason because I
could see it's a million other kid shows
and I give it a pass I only say it
because it's avatar and it's so fucking
good um well I'm at doshu the other
thing I thought was a little gimmicky
was opening up with Toph getting
captured and Katara say yo you brought
this on yourself it's like three days
earlier I hate those I I don't know what
is I think I'm just tired of it maybe um
maybe it's actually not a bad idea but
I've just seen it so much I'm like well
we know it's not really gonna add up to
this or we know something else is going
IV hell she's caught in a net and of
course she's gonna get out of the
fucking if this wasn't a scam um so but
that's a pet peeve um a lot of kids
watching I'm sure would be like wow
what's going on so I bet that that's uh
just a peppy thing and then the only
other thing you know I'm talking about a
lot of negative things about this
episode it's a good episode like I said
a very emotionally fueled episode and
for whatever reason I'm just picking up
these little epics but it bother me that
Aang said I give you the avatars promise
that I will not scam any more and it's
just a direct lie and again no he's a
kid got it but first of all he's not
doing it to an enemy he's doing it to
his best friend not just his best friend
like his love and he just straight-up
lies on his ever
car promise or whatever and if that's
even a thing probably not but he made it
sound like a fake a bike he broke a
promise and he broke it the millisecond
he was away from her and that I mean
okay he's a kid but he grew up with
monks monks come ha don't it's it's a
promise I did know I
I think promises very seriously so when
somebody it's just like I promise and it
just immediately scraps I'm like okay
that's that's really unlikable that just
drives me nuts so it now if there was
another way around if he said later well
I never said I would do scams this way
or that way if he found a way around it
that would be very smart and very I say
even a monk technically could get away
with that even though they know they're
kind of you know manipulating but but it
would count he technically wouldn't be
lying but there's nothing you just
straight up lies and that I didn't like
that that I don't expect a more of you
Aang so uh but I get that stuff that's
uh that's the minor stuff in this um
that this episode like I say it's a the
emotion is what really writes through on
it we get of course a little bit of
action near the end I'm not the best
action compared to the other ones but
again we're not that's not the focus of
this one's not supposed to be a super
action episode um again good comedy I'm
just thinking there's like a ton of
funny moments where I like laugh out
loud I love the scans the scans were
great and I love the way i love that
wish you would manipulate the rock back
into the bowl I love the way I love the
editing when soccer comes out as what
every angry either father or brother
whatever that sees a tough hit by the
carriage that they manipulate you just
see him fold his arms then you see a
money bag and another money bag and
another another another he goes okay
hilarious eh it's incredibly funny uh so
it's still really good episode it's got
great comedy it's got really good uh uh
really
good emotional center to it and and it
evens out well because honestly I was
watching this like how its tuffnut I
mean I know she doesn't get along with
their parents but it come on how is
there no remorse at all how are the no
feelings of her folks so it's so I'm
glad that it does sort of come back as
she does start to address it cuz I mean
I even though I know she's younger I
know she's you know only as they did a
bit of a fog like a like the wise thug
sorta um but well that's my way I could
describe her guy everything's just like
she doesn't like she's a good just like
punch
oh that's part of the charm too so I'm
glad they address that and to try to
think what else yeah just an all-around
just all-around good episode um some
problems here and there but like I say I
mean that's that's me really really
analyzing it I still think it came out
really really well
so um yeah that's about it and I'll see
you in the next one